the original meaning of the word
epigenetics was basically everything
that's not the genome right so so that
includes bioelectricity that right so so
traditionally that would include
biophysical factors biomechanical
factors um ionic factors and so on so
when we say at least when I say
epigenetic I don't just mean the
chromatin modifications that people
focus on today you know the methylation
the cation all that stuff but actually
all these other things so so we don't
know I mean there could be of course
there could be chromatin modification
effects but but we are you know the next
step is is to look at the the
bioelectrics and and probably
biomechanics too and other other um
aspects of the physiology of it